other girls um if you were in the
position of guys where the laws were
against you I didn't just say something
about it good it's interesting right
and so a lot of people do mention toxic
masculinity but I definitely think the
crisis that's happening now you can see
it it's if I label it is from toxic
feminine feministic I can't really say
the word popular because how do you how
do you expect people to express
themselves when they're scared men boys
are so scared to express themselves to
approach you but the main complaint from
all of my girlfriends or the people that
I know is the men are not being men
enough yeah they're not like literally
approaching exactly but look the Creator
yeah but then when we have laws like
that how can because I'm just thinking
if I was in their point of view and you
guys can tell me if you agree or
disagree but I would be really hesitant
if yeah